[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti io mi chiamo ezio e
oggi vi racconterò di connessioni
connessioni tra nuovi soggetti e nuovi
oggetti di apprendimento connessioni che
scaturiscono dall ascolto dall'ascolto
delle nuove generazioni che ho la
fortuna di vivere tutti i giorni al
lavoro e in famiglia che lavoro faccio
lavoro per un'azienda leader nel campo
dell'automazione e della robotica e qual
è il mio compito
io sono il direttore dell'académie sono
responsabili della formazione di 9 mila
persone nel mondo e al contempo sono
responsabile di aprire le porte
dell'azienda verso verso i giovani verso
l'esterno
lui mi vedete con lama camicia bianca
nella cerimonia di conclusione di un
executive master ma è un'esperienza di
ascolto che ho anche la fortuna di
vivere tutti i giorni in famiglia o
quattro figli ahimè tutti maschi avrei
tanto voluto la femmina e sono
disponibili allo scambio qualcheduno
avesse una figlia femmina da darmi e ho
tre figli francesco giacomo filippo e il
piccolo tesi fa che abbiamo deciso di
adottare dall etiopia e che vedete in
braccio i miei ragazzi come tutti i
giovani oggi frequentano un sistema di
istruzione che fatica ad affrontare la
sfida della conoscenza correlata
all'evoluzione tecnologica correlata
come la quarta rivoluzione industriale
sta cambiando totalmente la nostra vita
personale e professionale
eh sì
perché le nuove tecnologie
dell'intelligenza artificiale della di
the man who factoring dell'internet of
things della robotica collaborativa
stanno davvero cambiando il nostro
vissuto e soprattutto il modo col quale
le aziende idea non producono e
distribuiscono i propri prodotti e
servizi per lavorare con queste
tecnologie servono nuove competenze
nuove mentalità nuovi mestieri
serve allora un nuovo perimetro
formativo come ho scritto nel mio libro
che metta in connessione nuovi soggetti
i giovani la scuola l'università e
l'azienda ma che sappia mettere anche in
connessione nuovi oggetti di
apprendimento la tecnologia le
discipline scolastiche e la cultura del
lavoro
la storia che vi racconterò oggi è una
storia di come le accademie aziendali
stiano favorendo queste connessioni e di
come anche grazie a dei manufatti
innovativi stiano riuscendo a creare nei
giovani le competenze del futuro
iniziamo quindi dalle connessioni tra
nuovi soggetti di apprendimento alcune
iniziative che sono espressione di
queste connessioni sono quelle destinate
ai giovani talenti e perché no anche ai
professionisti alcuni esempi il
patentino della robotica oltre la
certificazione delle lingue la
certificazione informatica
un'iniziativa bellissima realizzata
dalle accademie aziendali insieme agli
insegnanti e questa mettere a
disposizione un programma per offrire ai
giovani di dotarsi delle competenze di
uso e programmazione di un robot
industriale sono già 5 mila i ragazzi
che in italia
sono entrati contatto con questa
certificazione quando avranno 18 anni
potranno lavorare in una fabbrica con
mille robot e guidarli e programmarli
un'altra iniziativa frutto di queste
connessioni è una summer school project
and people management
sì perché in questa evoluzione
tecnologica
dobbiamo gestire progetti essere molto
bravi nel gestire le persone dieci
giorni a shanghai
detroit oh beh l'orizzonte per acquisire
questi metodi e strumenti di nuovo
realizzata da chi da un academy
aziendale insieme all'università ma
l'iniziativa che più ci riempie di
orgoglio è un corso di laurea dal titolo
innovation and technology management
qual è la novità è che nello stesso
banco sono seduti e ingegneri sono
seduti laureati in fisica psicologi
sociologi antropologi e ottengono una
laurea interdisciplinare a proposito di
connessioni e sì perché questa quarta
rivoluzione industriale non deve essere
guidata solo dagli informatici ed agli
ingegneri ai quali voglio un sacco di
bene ma deve essere guidata anche dagli
psicologi dai sociologi dagli
antropologi dagli esperti dell'uomo
perché possano cogliere tutte le
opportunità dell'evoluzione tecnologica
cercando di mitigare i rischi
ecco alcune iniziative per i talenti ma
ci sono iniziative anche per i giovani
che sono già in azienda
sette anni ormai che viene realizzato
questo master manufaktur in 4.0 da
politecnico e da un academy aziendale i
ragazzi entrano nei aziendali si paga un
master sin dal primo giorno ogni mese
tre settimane di lavoro e una di master
erogato non solo dai docenti del
politecnico ma dai subject matter expert
dell'azienda è un ultima iniziativa
espressione di queste connessioni è un
executive master dove più di 40
dirigenti
provenienti da tutta europa stanno
acquisendo le competenze tecnologiche e
gestionali per guidare questa
trasformazione
ecco quindi realizzato il nuovo
perimetro formativo dove i ragazzi non
sono fruitori passivi di servizi erogati
dagli altri ma sono protagonisti
dell'innovazione dove la scuola
l'università non si limitano a fornire
teorie e modelli ma si immergono
all'interno della realtà aziendale della
realtà vera ed hanno il loro importante
e prezioso contributo un nuovo perimetro
formativo dove l'azienda non rinuncia
alla propria ambizione di creare e
diffondere cultura e di trasferirla alle
nuove generazioni con quelle di e nei
tipico dell'identità aziendale quelli
imparare facendo e quelli imparare
relazionandosi vorrei ora a raccontarvi
diciamo a di altre connessioni di altre
connessioni tra oggetti di apprendimento
discipline scolastiche tecnologia e
cultura di impresa
tutto nasce quando abbiamo iniziato a
sviluppare questo robot eravamo chiusi
in un laboratorio insieme a tanti
giovani e tante persone più esperte e
mentre eravamo lì abbiamo detto beh
facciamoci guidare da tre principi
vorremmo che questo robot fosse modulare
fosse aperto per un innovazione aperta e
fosse semplice da utilizzare e mentre
eravamo lì presi in questo laboratorio
in questo garage
siamo andati a visitare un accademia
aziendale che ha avuto un'idea
intelligente ha creato un progetto dal
nome la fisica in moto ha detto usiamo
le motociclette per attrarre ragazzi a
insegnare loro quanta fisica c'è dentro
una motocicletta e poi abbiamo pensato
alla nostra generazione e quella del
passato
millennio perché le motociclette erano
un simbolo della nostra generazione io e
tanti miei amici siamo cresciuti con tre
passaggi fondamentali 14 anni 16 anni e
18 anni questi sono i passaggi che hanno
scandito la nostra vita 14 anni cosa
c'era il motorino il cinquantino avere
il ciao avere il sì era un traguardo
fondamentale superato quel traguardo
c'erano i 16 anni sedici anni il
patentino della motocicletta al 125 io
avevo un cagiva elefant preistoria e
finalmente a 18 anni
la patente e la macchina su questo
aspetto generazionale voglio raccontarvi
un aneddoto della mia famiglia io e mia
moglie eravamo pronti ad affrontare le
richieste dei nostri figli rispetto a
questi tre passaggi e quindi a 14 anni
ci eravamo preparati per dire a
francesco le motivazioni per le quali
non vi avremmo mai comprato una
motocicletta
abbiamo fatto una lista come quella di
lorenzo pronti francesco non te la
compreremo mai
per questo per questo pronti 14 anni e
francesco non è venuto a chiederci nulla
abbiamo detto furbo francesco vuole il
125 aspettiamo due anni
teniamo il foglio l'abbiamo salvato in
una cartella speciale ea 16 anni eravamo
lì francesco non è venuto a chiederci
nulla neanche se 19 ha detto cavolo
questo vuole la macchina vuole una
macchina lunga da qui fino alla fine del
palco 18 anni
niente abbiamo dovuto mandarlo noi a
scuola guida per evitare di occuparci
dei servizi logistici il sabato sera e
questo cosa ci dice che le nuove
generazioni sono attratte da valori e da
oggetti diversi ovviamente dalla nostra
generazione sono attratti da dei tablet
dai telefoni casa mia la sera e un fare
diva nismo ognuno con il proprio tablet
o con il proprio telefono su facebook su
instagram questo
e il presente e chissà il futuro e
allora mentre sviluppavamo quel robot
abbiamo provato a dire ma il robot non è
ancora più affascinante di una
motocicletta per attirare le nuove
generazioni e così abbiamo proseguito
dicendo usiamola non solo per fare
coding per fare robotica ma per fare
matematica per fare fisica per fare
quelle materie stand che sono
fondamentali del futuro e abbiamo
costruita quella che noi chiamiamo una
roba experience intorno al robot una
serie di esperienze che mettessero in
connessione i giovani e robot laboratori
centri eventi programmi e questo breve
filmato vi fa vedere una di queste
iniziative
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco questo è un esempio di uno di
questi centri dove sono passati pensate
più di 10.000 ragazzi ma il nostro sogno
è un altro il nostro sogno è arrivare a
posizionare un robot in ogni scuola per
contribuire a innovare la didattica e
aiutare le nuove generazioni ad essere
protagonisti del futuro
eccola qui la magia non è robot ma sono
i nostri ragazzi un insegnante un
facilitatore un robot degli oggetti
semplici di legno che robot muove maker
muove nella realtà non all'interno di
uno schermo virtuale dove i nostri
ragazzi già passano fin troppo tempo
e poi c'è un tablet e sì perché questo
robot e semplice da utilizzare
la robotica sta vivendo quello che
accade ai personal computer negli anni
80 vi ricordate negli anni ottanta solo
seri un esperto di informatica poteri
usare lo spectrum all commodore 64
oggi invece i robot sono anzi i computer
sono nelle case di ciascuno di noi
ebbene la stessa cosa sta accadendo ai
robot fino ad oggi serviva un
programmatore per guidarli oggi anche i
nostri bambini
andrea alessia federico possono
utilizzarlo senza nessun tipo di corso e
si perchè c'è questa interazione che la
stessa che abbiamo nei nostri telefonini
questa interfaccia che con un solo dito
ti permette di comandarlo e di muoverlo
ma c'è anche una evoluzione in più può
essere programmato con block ii quindi
con quel pensiero e con quel linguaggio
logico computazionale che aiuta a
mettere in fila le cose e poi certo gli
informatici che vogliono sbizzarrirsi
tutta la vita
che tipo di attività vengono proposti
come avete visto nel video innanzitutto
lo montano i ragazzi ritorniamo a usare
la manualità e poi e poi ci giocano
imparare facendo così importante dal
punto di vista pedagogico man ma anche
andrà gotico
e poi affrontiamo e risolviamo dei
problemi che implicano l'utilizzo della
matematica della fisica matematica
qualche esempio la somma la sottrazione
l'equivalenza le figure geometriche che
i bambini delle elementari come alessia
surian tutti i giorni a scuola bene con
ed è ancora più divertente ancora più
efficace ma anche per i più grandicelli
qui abbiamo federico la geometria
analitica le equazioni di primo e
secondo grado
ecco così servono non per risolvere
degli esercizi e basta
ma per far muovere un robot robot edo
nello spazio
abbiamo quindi vissuto tante esperienze
abbiamo capito alcune cose 1 che questo
robot favorisce favorisce la
partecipazione l'inclusione anche i
bambini con dislessia con di hd anche il
mio piccolo test fa che ha un cromosoma
in più è disabile ma è bravissimo
nell'utilizzare questo robot e questo è
importante ma poi favorisce
l'applicazione delle materie alla realtà
l'inclusione e soprattutto favorisce
anche la diffusione di questa cultura
del lavoro che tanto preziosa lavorare
in team tenere tutto in ordine risolvere
problemi essere creativi avere pensiero
critico e anche mettere in connessione
mettere in connessione la dimensione
cognitiva quella manuale e quella
emotiva
vorrei chiudere con una frase di walt
disney
ecco il nostro sogno mettere in
connessione nuovi soggetti e nuovi
oggetti di apprendimento ma soprattutto
ascoltare i giovani e ho scelto di
chiudere il mio intervento con la foto
di mio figlio testa che sta ascoltando j
ax perché non dimentichiamoci che i
protagonisti del futuro sono loro
[Applauso]